everybody believes one thing's true and
the actual statistics aren't I'll give
you a couple of them okay however all
businesses borrow money it takes money
to make money
that's just complete bull I mean I know
bazillions of businesses that operate
debt-free lots of them do okay it's not
that unusual at all
it's just some broke finance professor
that's teaching you the benefit of bonds
or something then once you're you know
once you have a bond balancing in your
publicly traded company and so it's just
it's nuts
the second one is this family businesses
don't survive shirt sleeves to shirt
sleeves and three generations you ever
heard that one first generation builds
it up 2nd generation rides it in third
generation tears it down ever heard that
it's actually statistically not true
family businesses there's a whole
science around family business you can
actually get a degree in family business
from Kennesaw University now there are
family business conferences there's
whole reams of material written on
family business and there's tons of data
that show that family business privately
held family businesses are more
resilient and longer lasting than
publicly traded companies they outlast
them there's a bunch of them on the
landscape one of the most famous ones
that makes about 700 million skittles a
year Mars candy and pet food owned by
two sisters I think it's a twenty seven
billion dollar company if I remember
correctly two sisters on it I think it's
fifth generation or something like that
and nobody talks about it but
everybody's just like well you can't
hand it off to your kids because you you
know if you hand it off your kids it
ruins your kids and no you runs your
kids when the businesses fault lots of
businesses are handed off again I'll
point back to chick-fil-a you know
they're handing it off and doing a great
job the case study at Harvard on the
trigger on the Kathy family on how good
a job they've done on their succession
and transition planning and all that
kind of stuff lots of us have modeled
pieces of what we're
after them there's a lot of information
that's one of those myths you can't
borrow them you have to borrow money you
know here's another myth all right all
millionaires all rich people inherited
their money yeah heard that one bullcrap
statistical bullcrap we just finished
studying ten thousand one hundred and
sixty millionaires in depth largest most
comprehensive study piece of research
ever done on millionaires in North
America we're going to publish the
findings in Chris Hogan's new book that
will come out in January here's what we
found
79 percent of America's millionaires did
not receive a dime and inheritance
that's 8 out of 10 another 16% received
less than 100 thousand which
mathematically makes it impossible for
them to become a millionaire because of
an inheritance they became a millionaire
because they saved money and gone on a
debt no duh and so let's put those
numbers together that would be 89 that
would be 95 percent did I do that right
I did that right than that 95 percent
did not in their money see the problem
with that one is if you believe the all
bridge people won't hurt their money
then that lets you off the hook and you
don't have to get off your biding don't
make something of your life you can
blame everyone else and be a victim now
that just pissed off some politically
correct people didn't it good because
you have every opportunity to get up off
your butt and go be somebody so it
doesn't take money to make money all
family businesses don't fail and all
inherits and all millionaires didn't
inherit their money rich people all
inherited their money bull you don't
know what you're talking about
I've actually got I've got actual real
research the largest most comprehensive
piece of research ever done on the
subject can't touch this baby so that
you know that you just can't believe I'm
in thought you can't believe things that
are not true and have it and have no
packed on your life if you believed that
your business was going to ruin your
children's life why would you leave why
would you build a business and leave it
to your children if you believe that it
always the only way to start a business
and run a business is borrow money then
you're gonna go borrow money which by
the way is the number one cause of
business fail your cash flow problems
taxes and debt take down 80% of small
businesses in the first five years taxes
and debt they call it cashflow problems
and it's it's it you can't ignore truth
you can't ignore reality and adopt
mythology as your baseline you're plumb
line for your life and and get out of
that set of it out of that equation
unharmed you know it's like I believe
that running with scissors won't hurt me
so I run the scissors you were your
mother telling you not to run the
scissors why because you kill your but
don't do that you know I believe I don't
care what you believe
well I feel I don't care what you feel
what I want to know is what's real what
the truth is you can't feel your way
into the truth your feelings don't
matter you need to find out what the
truth is on some of these subjects and
align yourself with that and then go
there and so you know this idea that all
companies have debt all people have a
credit card every student has a student
loan everybody all these generalities
that cut they're all victims stuff
they're all instead of you being a
victor you get the opportunity to be a
victim and condi rice said it
beautifully last week when we were at
entree Leadership Summit she said as
soon as you assume the position of
victim you give your power to someone
else
woo mic drop as soon as I'm a victim I
just gave my power to someone else and
she was talking about racism and sexism
being an african-american lady and she
has suffered from both but she said I'm
not a victim as as soon as I'm a victim
of racism I'm a victim of sexism then I
just gave my power to the bully
jerk that was trying to pull that off
I'm not giving my power to the hell I'm
gonna triumph over them a Victoire not a
victim
oh man that lady is something she's got
an intellect that'll curl your hair if I
had something but man I'm impressive but
you know I'm talking about don't you
know other lines she dropped men she had
some Twitter line tweetable lines
doesn't matter what she said she grew up
in Birmingham in a segregated
neighborhood and she said all my parents
told me my whole life was not you're
from the hood not from here from this
she said all they told me is it doesn't
matter where you're coming from all that
matters is where you're going to that'll
preach doesn't matter where you're
coming from all it matters is where
you're going too buddy of mine come from
a rough neighborhood he said Dave
getting out of the hood is easier and
getting the hood out of you see that's
the difference in a victim and a
Victoire you got to decide don't you the
neat thing is you have the power you
just get to decide you have the power of
choice you decide which one you're gonna
be I love it I love it I love it I love
it believe the truth and act on it this
is the Dave Ramsey show